what does character development entail
are you writing a backstory to me that's
everything it's everything here's
another one my sayings ready begin with
character and with character find the
story in between I don't care what
paradigm people have in terms of story
structure how you get there is critical
and so you start with your characters
that's my take you know it forget
there's not one right way to do this I'm
just saying that this I think is a
there's a smart way to go about it
because the characters it's their story
if we're writing a story we are assuming
that in some magical mystical way that
story universe exists those characters
exist and if it's their story they know
it better than we do and so character
development is about getting curious
it's about asking questions it's about
spending time with the characters and so
the typical things that we see like
biographies and questionnaires
those are great I call those in direct
engagement exercises because you're
reflecting on the character you're
thinking about the character as opposed
to direct engagement exercises so for
example what if I have a character in
mind I'm going to imagine I am a
psychiatrist this character is my
patient and if they're reticent to talk
to me I can even go and step further
they have been court-appointed to appear
with me as a psychiatrist and they have
to answer my questions that they don't
they will stay stuck in the situation
until they do so you just create a
situation in which like I was saying
earlier you just ask questions you get
curious when I was but that's a lesson I
learned when I was an Air Force brat you
just ask people questions I'm talking
and so you just you type you just let it
go you can even do something it's a
little bit spiritual I suppose you'd say
in a way where you're gonna do either a
monologue or a stream of consciousness
with a character it's sort of like a
Vulcan mind meld you know like Star Trek
where you get a character in your mind
and you do some deep breathing you get
yourself so you're transitioning out of
the busy world and you're gonna be here
now with this character and you set a
timer for like 15
that's you put your fingers on the
keyboard or pin on paper and you close
your eyes and you just type and you just
type and you know your mind will go oh I
got to get groceries or the cat whatever
just look like though you don't get
attached to it you just keep coming back
to this character and you get done with
this and so you've got all these words
that you've typed out some of them are
like dialogue like a monologue and some
of them are just like stream of
consciousness
80% of it may seem like gobbledygook to
you maybe 90% but 20% or 10% there's
something really interesting that popped
out there and that's getting in touch
with the characters in at a subconscious
level and they start to talk to you I've
seen this happen time and time again I
created a a prep class 10 years ago that
I teach online six-week workshop taking
a story from concept to outline and the
first four weeks are all character
development the second week is brain
storming that's all they do is
brainstorm
and I've had hundreds of people tell me
that was the most eye-opening experience
for them was doing that type of work
again the characters exist we act on
that belief and we reach out to them and
get them talking to us so the character
development that's those some great
examples are character development can
happen out of that is if you identify a
protagonist in particular their state of
disunity where they are disconnected
from their authentic nature and that can
inform if you know what the disunity
state is that can inform where the Unity
State is and so now they're not gonna
just jump there then you're gonna say
okay so these plot elements and a
characters with whom they intersect
they're gonna deconstruct their old ways
of being because they don't work out
here in the new world but in the process
of that they're gonna uncover their need
their needs going to start to emerge
this is very Union young talks about he
says when an inner situation is not made
conscious and he's talking about like
conflict inner conflict it happens
outside as fate
now I don't know if that's real and you
know in the real world but that's the
protagonist story the protagonist arts
off in a state of disunity and what
happens and the plot is informed by that
there's a synergy between it it's not
just these random events it's like these
characters that they intersect with and
the events that they go through that's
going to provide the basis of their
transformation and so their disunity
that gets deconstructed well now this
stuff starts to come out into the light
of consciousness their need and then
they move into reconstruction now
they're moving into their new mode of
being and eventually toward unity so you
can take that raw material that you get
with your with your characters and see
how that starts to shape the nature of
the plot the story structure and it's
not just plugging this in you know this
has to happen on page 25 the the
break-in to act to know you're doing it
through a much more organic fashion with
your characters and letting them inform
you what what the structure will be and
the final value of that is that you're
writing multi-layered richly textured
characters who actors want to play so
character development to me is like
everything it it's absolutely critical
you